in sunshine will be using content
providers to help us efficiently sync
data from the internet combined with the
utilities in the android framework it
also simplifies getting database content
to and from our user interface we
implement a content provider by
extending the content provider clasps in
sunshine will call this class whether
provider will use the weather provider
to read and write the database we just
created you're probably excited to get
started on building our weather provider
but if you're still unsure about what
content providers are and how they work
we've built a great exercise that
demonstrates how to take advantage of
all this na religious goodness wine our
licious because this exercise leverages
the user dictionary provider so if you
ever wanted to make your radical osha's
vocabulary ousness better understood by
your mobile friend pan yin while
learning more about content providers
check the instructor notes below for a
link to the bonus lesson building a
content provider involves several steps
determining the URIs your application
will need to support updating the
contract to include these URIs filling
out a URI mattre that supports each of
these URIs and implementing the six
required content provider functions ok
the task is determining URIs but what's
a URI anyhow a content provider allows
us to think of the data associated with
our views in terms of universal resource
identifiers zor you are eyes your eyes
do exactly what their name implies they
identify a resource in our case a row or
rows in a database you're almost
certainly familiar with the concept of a
URI since the URL used for every web
address is actually a type of uri in the
case of the web it's a URI used to
identify web content with an HTTP or
HTTPS scheme in this example sunshine is
using a URI to query the weather for the
9 40 43 location our content provider
returns a cursor containing the database
rows that correspond to the URI by
changing the query value of the URI we
can have sunshine displayweather from
different parts of the country ETR I can
contain the content scheme a scheme is
the first part of you
that precedes the colon and it
identifies the protocol that the URI
will be using you are used to seeing
schemes such as HTTP and ftp and you are
is content colon implies that the URI
refers to a content provider a Content
authority which is a unique string used
to locate your content provider and it
should almost always be the package name
of the application a location which
typically points to a database table
within the application an optional query
this query can either be part of the uri
path or it can take the form of a
traditional uri query following a
question mark as it turns out a uri is
the primary piece of data that is passed
in these intense that rato so gloriously
described in sunshine will leverage this
to start the detail view with a uri that
points to the weather on a specific day
the detailed view uses this uri to query
whether provider and get the right
weather data to display another thing
that these content provider URIs is used
for an androids to notify the user
interface that a piece of the data it is
displaying has changed the code
registers an android contract called a
Content observer during our initial
query against the uri that is being
displayed when running a database update
routine likely on another thread that
routine will tell android that the data
associated with the URI has changed and
ultimately that the uri should require
you the database and refresh the display
this will cause a display to refresh and
show the latest data even though as you
can see here the URI hasn't changed
content providers can return all sorts
of data that the abstract functions
return either a cursor containing a list
of items or a single item how these URIs
are structured is up to each application
but Android provides support for a
pending and ID to the URI path to
indicate that the application is
interested in a specific record rather
than a range of records in sunshine the
value for a specific date and time is
appended to the query for whether at a
specific location and that causes a
single weather record to be returned so
defining you are is to make it easy for
us I've defined these data URIs that
will be supporting some of these your
eyes exist because the UI is a view that
needs to
Bose that particular data such as
whether with location which will be used
to display the main list of forecasts
and of course whether with location and
date which will be used to display the
detailed forecast information others are
used primarily for writing the database
inserts updates and deletes having these
base URIs is also useful for testing now
it's time to go back to our weather
contract when we first described what a
weather contract is we said that it is
an agreement between the data models
storage and views presentation
describing how information is accessed
it turns out that in addition to the
column names for our database the
contract is also a great place to define
the you are is that our application will
be using to access its data next we'll
explain what you need to add to your
weather contract when you've completed
adding this code to your project I'll
explain a bit about what you've done